everything that you do if you're Muslim
because if you do didn't throw you off
the plane number one nothing there's an
emergency and the residents of bhavani
you know making fun of Islam is actually
an act that can make you out of the fold
of Islam very easy actually even if you
don't have the intention and what I
respect about my brother and I want to
applaud them for listen and see is that
a lot of failure that you're operating
the Holland way but you can tilt it's a
message and he doesn't cross the
boundaries of the religion and that's
why we invited my body and that's why we
love him and the kids love him because
of this because there are a lot of
stand-up comedians Islamic ones now who
make fun of our religion in order to
make the people laugh and this is not
acceptable in Islam whatsoever
this is actually an act that we can take
you out of the hold of his lap that is
an evocative Arabic give up the woodwork
you know like if you didn't we have a
surprise we have a son
one of the brothers will attract the
staff to money that's a blessing what
does it mean huh
miss hello I will have blood of any
nudists you want to have a conversation
with him please how he accepted it that
are you excited excited is there anybody
else out there anyone else then the not
get Muslims or like to do what he's
doing
taking that brave courageous step and
giving birth to what's already inside
the human being would like to accept
Islam does anybody else company that
miss Geller tell us in a few words what
was it about Islam that had you now here
with us tonight
[Music]
co-workers many co-workers that are
Muslim yes
we used to study with media and they
used to
[Music]
I decided to change back service what
background you come from my father my
cousin is a prince it will feel like a
bigger challenge father was a priest and
[Music]
let me make a really easy example for
our viewers out there who also might be
contemplating you've been thinking about
what the purpose of life is why you're
here where you're going and now you did
what our brother here did you started to
reflect and somebody shared because they
cared it's like a house you're invited
to a house with four rooms and the
person takes you into one room and he
invites you to worship a sticks stone
bone idols and you're fit that all your
innate nature we just that so we go to
room number two and then they invite you
to worship a human being they invite you
to worship something else from creation
and you say no thank you
then you move on to room number three
and rule number three has the roof off
of it it's open and then they say look
up at the Sun why don't you worship the
Sun worship the stars worship Mother
Nature and you say no you mean genuine
sincere with your Victor your nature you
say I'll pass and then someone takes you
to room number four and there's no
statue no picture nothing but the
attributes of the one who created you
explain go to our blog wahad
oh la ville summit let me on each one
one had say he is God Allah the one and
only the absolute the eternal he begets
not nor is He begotten there's nothing
comparable to him would you accept that
yes will you call her that I'm going to
twist your arm put a gun to you force
you to do this no Allahu Akber do you
know that when someone accepts
submission to the will of the creator of
the heavens and earth he's following the
way of Jesus of Moses of Abraham
continuing the same legacy is the same
way of life it's not a new religion it's
the same way of life the same religion -
my lashes am i right everybody so now
when someone does that all their
previous sins what they did in the past
yo somebody money - did something wrong
they get right but with god you're all
right you're all good you know what's
coming $1 for your sins no one returns
to the most loving the most merciful and
heat for kids and you're doing you're
taking that free choice that you have to
worship a stick stone and bone I go to
these other wolves you know you're doing
it now for the creator of the heavens
and earth so you're ready yes
so repeat up the beat we'll start off
with English and then we'll go on to the
Arabic I testify I bear witness I just
finally know if there is nothing worthy
of worship
there's nothing worse they avoid except
the creator of the heavens and earth
except the creator of God Almighty Allah
got a wedgie along and I bear witness
I testify as I justify my husband peace
and blessings be upon him is his final
slip final messenger his final messenger
are you ready in there be a shadow and
why should I do
Asha and [ __ ] with beer yeah yeah
all right well we're not right here stop
this is very very important this is the
exciting part now the work has to start
I want somebody to be dedicated to him
as a guardian angel someone who's gonna
help we're colleagues up at six knots
what are we going I need someone look if
you don't believe someone was gonna
teacher than fattiness someone's gonna
teach him how to pray the fundamentals
step by step there's a really great also
research so we already got you too
brother
okay so we got the brother here then
who's going to go ahead and be that
mentor you also there's new Muslim
Academy new Muslim Academy calm because
now it's not just it's a lifestyle it's
a way of life you've got to get grounded
in it you got to learn and that's how
you're gonna go to experience all the
blessings that have the audacity welcome
to summer long I quote my along here
Nikhil inshallah we will upload the
again please collect your shop
[Music]
[ __ ] he brought it into my old phone yes
my brother are you doing I know this guy
from a long time ago much more amazing
work yo Cindy show CD show this the fan
of the B shows amazing give us approval
put the three the three got to do if
you're Muslim because if you do they're
gonna throw you off the plane number one
no matter how good the food is don't
ever say it's the bomb because if you do
they're gonna throw you off the plane
number two if you see a friend named
Jack don't say hi to him when a Muslim
says hi jack it's even you're thrown off
the plane and finally if you are a guy
who has a sister sister ring the job if
you got the plane but if you have a
beaut and you bring a job they're
definitely gonna throw you off the plane
and they probably have some questions to
you at the muster saying further what
are you doing that's my boy bevarly so
I'll they go